the u.s military says this morning it
has successfully shut down a
medium-range ballistic missile in a test
exercise this image released by the
military shows the scheduled maneuver
just off the coast of hawaii the test
comes one day after the firing of a
north korean ballistic missile new video
this morning is giving us our first look
at that launch the north korean missile
was fired from the capital pyongyang and
flew over u.s ally japan u.s ambassador
to the u.n nikki haley said north
korea's
lawlessness will not be allowed to
continue ben tracy is in tokyo with how
the missile triggered warnings and
widespread concern across japan ben good
morning
good morning so japanese officials say
this missile launch came as a complete
surprise and we now know that neither
japan nor the u.s tried to shoot it down
because the missile was flying too high
over the island now the missile that was
launched is what north korea calls its
hasson 12. this is the first time the
regime has launched a missile from its
capital city and doing so makes a
preemptive strike by the u.s more
difficult because it shows north korea
can put its missiles in unpredictable
and highly populated areas now north
korean state media says kim jong-un was
at the launch site and deemed it
successful state media also said that
sending a missile over japan was north
korea's way of quote muscle flexing in
response to u.s and south korean
military exercises that have been taking
place since last week it called this a
curtain razor with more north korean
actions to come now kim jong-un has
instructed his military to launch more
missiles into the pacific but he says
he'll also wait and see what the united
states decides to do and then respond
accordingly
gail
thank you very much ben tracy reporting
from tokyo